STRIKES BACK, AND SCHUMER'S
REVENGE.
THAT GEORGE W. BUSH BECAME THE
CANDIDATE TO THE PRESIDENCY WAS
A MEMBER OF SKULL AND BONES.
IT'S THAT YALE UNIVERSITY SUPER
MYSTERIOUS CLUB THAT WAS FOUNDED
IN 1832.
SO CREEPY.
TURNS OUT THAT, ACCORDING TO AN
INFORMANT, ANTI-TRUMP FBI
INVESTIGATOR PETER STRZOK AND
HIS GAL PAL FBI LAWYER LISA PAGE
SPOKE IN TEXT MESSAGES ABOUT A
TO DISCUSS THINGS LIKE INSURANCE
POLICIES AND OTHER BENEVOLENT
MATTERS INVOLVING DONALD TRUMP.
SENATOR RON JOHNSON TODAY WAS
FLABBERGASTED AT WHAT HE LEARNED
FLABBERGASTED AT WHAT HE LEARNE
FURTHER EVIDENCE OF CORRUPTION
AT THE HIGHEST LEVEL OF THE FBI.
A SECRET SOCIETY?
HOLDING SECRET MEETINGS
OFF-SITE.
THERE IS SO MUCH SMOKE.
THERE ARE SIMILAR INDIVIDUALS
HIGHLY BIASED, POLITICAL
OPERATIVES BURROWED INTO THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AS WELL.
>> Laura: YOU COMBINE THIS
WITH THE SUDDEN MISSING FIVE
MONTHS OF TEXTS BETWEEN THE TWO
LOVEBIRDS, AND YOU DO HAVE A
FULL-BLOWN CORRUPTION SCANDAL ON
YOUR HANDS, INVOLVING THE VERY
MRS. CLINTON'S PRIVATE EMAIL
SERVER AND OF THE RUSSIA
COLLUSION NONSENSE EVOLVING
ROLLING JUST KNOWING WHAT WE
JOE DID YOU HAVE A MADE THE CASE
THAT THIS ALL INDICATES THAT
DEPARTMENT.
>> QUITE APPARENT THAT
CHRISTOPHER WRAY IS NOT UP TO
THE JOB OF BEING FBI DIRECTOR,
THAT HE IS UNDERMINING HIS
CREDIBILITY, NOT STRENGTHENING
IT.
AND THAT HE IS COMPLETELY,
COMPLETELY CONTROLLED BY THE
UPPER BUREAUCRACY OF THE FBI.
THE OTHER REAL PROBLEM IS ROD
ROSENSTEIN.
I DON'T THINK THERE IS ANY, ANY
DOUBT WHATSOEVER THAT ROSENSTEIN
IS TOO CLOSE TO CALL ME, TOO
CLOSE TO MUELLER, TOO CLOSE TO
WRAY, AND TOO CLOSE TO A WHOLE
BUNCH OF PEOPLE.
JEFF SESSIONS SEEMS TO HAVE
DECIDED IF HE COULD HAVE A
LITTLE BIT OF FUN WITHIN THE
BOUNDARIES OF THE PLAYING FIELD,
IN MARKET ANYBODY MAD AT HIM,
THAT'S GOING TO BE ENOUGH TO GET
THE JOB DONE.
>> Laura: IT WAS UGLY.
PUBLIC HAS A RIGHT TO KNOW WHAT,
IF ANY, CRIMES OR OTHER
IMPROPRIETIES WERE COMMITTED BY
THE MEMBERS OF THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION AND MEMBERS OF
BLEEDING HAS GOT TO STOP NOW.
THE DOJ AND THE FBI, THEY HAVE
TO BE PURGED OF ANYONE ACTIVELY
WORKING TO UNDERMINE THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION WITH A POLITICAL
AGENDA AND BE PURGED OF ANYONE
TYPE OF WRONGDOING, WHO IS
SERVING FROM THE GOVERNMENT.
THEY SHOULDN'T BE SERVING THE
GOVERNMENT AT ALL.
THEY SHOULD BE FIRED.
AND NOW ONTO SCHUMER'S REVENGE.
THEY WERE BRIEF MOMENTS IN THE
LEAD UP TO THE GOVERNMENT
SHUTDOWN LAST WEEK WHEN
CHUCK SCHUMER SEEMED TO BE
COMING TO HIS SENSES ON THE
ISSUE OF THE LAW.
HERE HE WAS ON FRIDAY.
>> IN EXCHANGE FOR A STRONG
PROTECTIONS, I RELUCTANTLY PUT
THE BORDER WALL ON THE TABLE FOR
DISCUSSION.
EVEN THAT WAS NOT ENOUGH TO
ENTICE THE PRESIDENT INTO
FINISHING THE DEAL.
>> Laura: NOW IT'S BEEN
ANNOUNCED THAT CHUCK IS TAKING
BORDER WALL FUNDING OFF THE
TABLE IN AN IMMIGRATION POLICY
NEGOTIATION.
THIS MAN HAS PROBABLY LOST HIS
MIND.
HE JUST HAD HIS POLITICAL CLOCK
CLEANED FOR THIS RIDICULOUS
GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN THE GOT HIM
NOTHING.
NOW HE'S GOING TO TAKE THE ONE
IMMIGRATION MUST HAVE FOR
REPUBLICANS IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
FLAKE-GRAHAM-DURBIN BILL THAT
TRUMP AND NICK LAST WEEK, THAT
ALL LED TO SCHUMER SHUTTING
DOWN THE GOVERNMENT IN THAT BIG
HISSY FIT.
SERIOUS BORDER SECURITY, AND TO
TRAIN MIGRATION, CANCELLATION OF
THE OUTDATED AND UNSAVED VISA
LOTTERY, AND A PERMANENT
SOLUTION TO DACA.
IMPORTANTLY, THE
FLAKE-GRAHAM-DURBIN AGREEMENT
DID NOT REACH THESE BENCHMARKS.
IN FACT, IT WILL NOT SECURE OUR
BORDER, ENCOURAGE MORE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION, INCREASE CHAIN
MIGRATION, AND RETAIN THE VISA
LOTTERY SYSTEM.
IN SHORT, IS TOTALLY
UNACCEPTABLE TO THE PRESIDENT
SHOULD BE CLICK DECLARED DEAD ON
ARRIVAL.
>> Laura: I LOVE HEARING DEAD
ON ARRIVAL WHEN IT COMES TO A
BAD IMMIGRATION BILL.
IT'S WHAT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
WANT.
MEMBER THAT NEW HARVARD HARRIS
POLL WE TOLD YOU ABOUT LAST
NIGHT?
A LOT OF PEOPLE HAVEN'T FOCUSED
ON THIS.
INADEQUATE.
54% HAVE RESPONDED, WANT A WALL
OR OTHER BARRIER BUILT ACROSS
THE U.S. MEXICAN BORDER?
WHILE THEY DO WANT TO HELP THE
DACA PEOPLE AND GIVE SOME KIND
OF PROTECTION TO THEM, THEY
DON'T WANT TO BE LEFT
CHUCK SCHUMER IS UNDER ENORMOUS
GROUPS ARE INSISTING THAT HE
RESIST THE PRESIDENT AND FIGHT
HIM ON EVERYTHING, INCLUDING
IMMIGRATION.
WHY ARE THEY DOING THIS?
BECAUSE THEY WANT TO SEE THE
DAWN OF A NEW GOVERNING
MAJORITY, AND IT'S COMING ACROSS
AUTOMATICALLY REGISTERING ANY
ADULTS WHO OBTAINED A DRIVER'S
LICENSE TO VOTE IN THE STATE.
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN GRANTING
FOX NEWS ESTIMATES THAT A
MILLION ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
ALREADY HAVE SECURED A LICENSE
TO DRIVE IN THE GOLDEN STATE, BY
THE END OF LAST YEAR.
TURNING THEM INTO INSTANT VOTERS
IS SURE TO CHANGE THE OUTCOME OF
ANY ELECTION, NOW THAT THERE IS
A SUPER MAJORITY IN THE STATE
FOR DEMOCRATS.
THAT'S SO SHOCKING.
SPEAKING OF THESE ISSUES THAT
THE PRESIDENT, AND I KNOW
SOMEBODY THAT YOU REALLY CARE
ABOUT, YOU HEAR A LOT ABOUT
IMPORTANT FOR YOU TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT IT IS.
HOW IT TRANSFORMS THE COUNTRY,
AND WHY IT MUST END.
ALSO PART OF THE TRUMP MUST
HAVES ON IMMIGRATION.
THIS IS A WHITE HOUSE GRAPHIC
THAT WE SHARE WITH YOU
EXCLUSIVELY TONIGHT.
FOR EVERY HOUR THE U.S. SETTLES
ENOUGH MIGRANTS TO FILL A SMALL
AUDITORIUM.
THAT'S REALLY SMALL PRINT.
EVERY DAY, ENOUGH TO FEEL A
LARGE HIGH SCHOOL.
EVERY MONTH, WE SETTLE ENOUGH TO
EVERY YEAR, AN IMMIGRANT
POPULATION LARGER THAN THE SIZE
OF WASHINGTON, D.C.
EVERY YEAR, WE RESETTLE A
174,000 PARENTS OF FOREIGN BORN,
ELDERLY.
THEY WILL BE TAKING A LOT OF
SERVICES OUT.
THEY ARE PAYING BASICALLY
NOTHING IN THE SYSTEM ONCE THEY
PROGRAMS THAT YOU PAY FOR THEIR
RETIREMENT.
IN ALL OF THIS, PROBABLY -- AND
AT HARVARD HARRIS POLL, 65-35%
OF AMERICANS SUPPORT A DOCTOR AD
OF AMERICANS SUPPORT A DOCTOR AC
OF AMERICANS SUPPORT A DOCTOR AA
OF AMERICANS SUPPORT A DOCTOR AD
OF AMERICANS SUPPORT A DOCTOR AL
THE ENDS CHAIN MIGRATION,
ELIMINATES THE VISA LOTTERY, AND
SECURES THE BORDER WALL.
79% OF THE PEOPLE IN THE SAME
POLE WANT IMMIGRATION BASED ON
MERIT, NOT FAMILY TIES.
79% AGREE WITH THE PRESIDENT.
IT'S TIME FOR THE DEMOCRATS TO
START PUTTING THE HOPE IN DREAMS
OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE FIRST.
IT IS NOW CRYSTAL CLEAR THAT
SCHUMER AND THE DEMOCRATS ARE
GOING TO RUN OVER THE AMERICAN
WORKER AND RISK THEIR SAFETY, IF
THAT'S WHAT IT TAKES, TO KILL